[Music]
Carlos Seville may have been born on the
Isle of the lost but he doesn't have a
bad bone in his body he's come a long
way from being the timid and terrified
kid he used to be and we just can't get
over his transformation watch until the
very end to find out just how much
Carlos has evolved since we first saw
him in the original descendants film
part 1 descendants Carlos de Vil was
born and raised on the Isle of the lost
his mother Cruella De Vil had Lula for
her son and chose to manipulate him
every chance she got despite being a
super intelligent individual Carlos is
known for being somewhat gullible for
years he believed but dogs were rampant
beasts who feasted on little boys karela
instilled the spear into him when he was
just a toddler so he grew up fearing
canines above anything else Carlos is an
only child and little is known about his
father who goes unmentioned for the most
part Carlos had a very sad upbringing
and was tormented both at home and in
the outside world since Carlos is known
for being smaller and weaker than the
other decays he was often chased beat
and bullied by his peers but these
challenges were nothing compared to what
his mother did to him
for most of his life Carlos was forced
to touch up Karelas root fluff her first
scrape the bunions off her feet and
basically do whatever she asked of him
however none of this ever succeeded in
breaking Carlos's spirit which is
arguably what makes his character so
unique Carlos is tech savvy and
super-smart which is what's allowed him
to be the BK's at their own game when we
first meet Carlos in the original
descendants film he is a shell of a
person sure he likes to be wicked every
now and then but he's at his mother's
beck and call
this all changes when Prince Ben invites
Carlos who attend our Adan Prep at first
he's not too fond of the idea but as
soon as he hears karela bark out a
command he realizes that distancing
himself from mother dearest won't be
such a bad thing however his intense
fear of dogs stops him from being
excited about the whole ordeal thing
really start to change for Carlos when
he moves to auradon and realizes that
heroes aren't as bad as they seem
here Carlos is allowed to pursue his
passions which revolve around technology
video games and eating a boatload of
chocolate being the nice guy that he is
Carlos starts to make friends and even
tries joining a sports team however he
soon realizes that sports simply aren't
his forte throughout the first movie
Carlos demonstrates just how smart he is
by disabling the museum's alarm and
altering his 3d printer without his help
the BK's would have been sent back to
the aisle in no time still Carlos is
plagued by his mother's influence and is
terrified of canines to the point of no
return
or so we thought it's no secret that
Carlos and his friends are the best
dressed kids in auradon
thanks to Evie Carlos is always seen
wearing amazing outfits that truly
encompass his villainous background
Cruella and Carlos couldn't be any more
difference when it comes to personality
but their fashion sense is wildly
similar when it comes to Carlos's style
it's safe to say that he takes a page
from his mother's book we often see him
wearing red black and white with the
occasional hint of fur
his classic outfit is made of leather
and screams Deville his jacket has red
sleeves while its body is half white and
half black this is also the case for his
leather capris once it art on prep
Carlos swaps his leather outfit for a
more school friendly attire
however he continues to stick to karelas
colors and in good fashion Carlos tends
to keep a piece of black and white fur
attached to his hip Carlos his style
changes as he gets older but he never
strays too far from what he's used to
Carlos can easily be spotted out thanks
to his hair which is white at the tips
and black at the roots he's got a pale
complexion that is dusted with freckles
but his most appealing feature is his
wide brown eyes Carlos might come off as
wicked but he's actually super sweet in
fact he's living proof that we shouldn't
judge a book by it's cover
if there's one thing that's always held
Carlos back it's his mother Cruella
he was taught to fear dogs above
everything else which allowed her to
manipulate him but once he was far away
from her treacherous influence Carlo
began to realize that canines weren't as
bad as he was led to believe while
training with the future king of our Don
Carlos was chased by the school mutt
what was supposed to help him improve
his speed turned into a total nightmare
dude the dog chased Carlos into the
forest where the VK attempted to climb a
tree to escape mutilation this is when
Prince van realized just how hard the
BK's had it back home then helped Carlos
realize that dogs were friendly
creatures who were known as man's best
friend he encouraged Carlos to get to
know dude which changed his life for the
better then and there Carlos realized
that his mother had been lying to him
for his entire life this revelation
helped Carlos sever ties with his mother
so when Carlos chatted with his mother
via webcam on family day
he stood up to her for the very first
time his newfound courage changed him
for the better by overcoming his fear of
dogs
Carlos was truly able to make peace with
his past and move on to a brighter
future so when it was time to steal
fairy godmothers wand
Carlos chose to be good as long as he
never had to see Mommy Dearest again
part two descendants - in descendants -
Carlos and his friends are no longer on
probation when it comes to attending our
Don prep Carlos is now a dog lover who's
no longer ruled by his mother's wicked
ways instead he's focused on trying to
improve his own life for the very first
time
although dude the dog is a free mutt who
doesn't have an owner he can be found by
Carlos's side both day and night Carlos
now has amazing friends a happy living
situation and a pet dog but something is
still missing from his life we learned
early on that Carlos is crushing on
fairy godmothers daughter Jane Carlos
asks Jay for dating advice but soon
regrets it because Jay doesn't yet know
what it means to fall in love all Carlos
wants is to be able to talk to Jane
without fumbling over his words he also
wants to ask her out and be her dates
for the cotillion
Carlos is definitely more confident than
before but he still has a lot of work to
do
and
it comes to his feelings Carlos is far
from being an open book Carlos has
always been a nice guy and that's
something that will never change still
he was raised by villains so he's used
to taking shortcuts when it comes to
getting what he wants after trying to
tell Jane how he feels on more than one
occasion
Carlos chooses to take a simpler route
he asks mal to make him a truth gummy
with the intention of eating it and
telling Jane how he feels
however mal warns him that a truth gummy
can backfire since he'll be compelled to
tell the truth and nothing but the truth
despite the risk
Carlos chooses to bite the bullet this
just goes to show how brave and selfless
Carlos truly is he's willing to
embarrass himself in order to tell Jane
how he truly feels fortunately his plans
change when dude eats the gummy and now
returns to the Isle of the Lost it's
here that we see how brave and loving
Carlos truly is he returns to the aisle
to save his friend which is the one
place he never wanted to return to
coincidentally this unexpected adventure
brings his confidence to a whole new
level
Carlos's personality isn't the only
thing that undergoes a transformation in
descendants to the BK's wardrobe also
takes a massive turn for the better
while we're used to seeing Carlos in
white red and black Evie adds silver to
his look and it does him justice in
descendants to Carlos's hair has dyed a
silvery white his black roots are less
noticeable and he's traded in his capris
for full-length pants his leather jacket
is much more colorful than it used to be
and he's totally ditched the fur all in
all Carlos's look is much more grown-up
still he hasn't forgotten who his mother
is which is made obvious by the spots on
his jacket and the crisscross bones on
his satchel Carlos might be a good guy
but he's not about to trade his wicked
fashion sense for our gold star although
Carlos prefers a more sporty look he
knows how to dress up for the occasion
the young VK looked dashing in his
cotillion outfit which was also designed
by Evie here we see just how Carlos has
grown
in six short months he looks
sophisticated in his white and black
leather jacket white dress shirt and red
capris
he's also got red leather gloves to
match still this is just the beginning
of his coming-of-age story at first
glance Carlos appears to have it all
he's brave kind giving and has
genius-level intellect still there's one
thing Carlos could improve on and that's
his confidence coincidentally the same
can be said about Jane after saving King
been from uma and her crew the V Ches
returned to our Adan just in time for
the cotillion problem is Carlos still
doesn't have a date but after clashing
swords with the Pirates and escaping a
deadly fate old insecurities are the
least of his worries
Carlos locates Jane and asks her out but
she's talking on the phone and it's
clear that Carlos is in the friend zone
that is until he pulls her phone from
her ear and tells her he wants to take
her to the cotillion
and hopefully be more than friends this
is something the old Carlos would never
have done instead he chose to be
confident and persistent which totally
caught Jane's attention Carlos went from
being a shy and insecure person to a
go-getter in the nick of time and it's
all thanks to King been getting himself
kidnapped instead of relying on a truth
gummies to get the girl Carlos chose to
be himself and ended up winning his
crushes heart
unfortunately Carlos and Jane's romantic
adventures won't last for too long
because the dark threat is coming to our
Adan
part three descendants three it's no
secret that the vks are about to face
their biggest threat yet the third and
final installment to the descendants
franchise is set to hit the small screen
in the summer of 2019 it's safe to say
that Carlos's evolution is about to hit
a milestone Carlos may have grown
accustomed to the good life but his past
is coming back to haunt him everything
he knows and loves will be challenged
and he's bound to reach a new level of
excellence from the trailer we know that
Carlos and his friends are being
targeted by a menacing villain who will
stop at nothing to put mal in her place
but being the brave and dedicated friend
that he is Carlos will undoubtedly risk
his own life to save our Don once and
for all so far we know that Carlos evie
been dude and Jay will all be turned to
stone we also know that Jane's mother
will also meet the same fate so Carlos
will be trying to avenge his future
fairy mother-in-law while attempting to
save the world
the trailers place Carlos and some very
intense fight scenes and his character
is bound to reach new heights as this
ominous threat approaches Carlos grew up
in a very toxic setting which caused him
to doubt himself and those around him
luckily he was chosen to attend our don
prep and his personality changed for the
better the last time we saw Carlos he
was dancing the night away with his new
girlfriend Jane and it's safe to assume
that their bond has only grown since
then Carlos is now a confident hero and
a valuable ally on his quest to rid
Aradhana of evil Carlos will surely put
his tech-savvy abilities to the test
sadly we know for a fact that Carlos
isn't going to make it to the finish
line instead he'll be turned to stone
while attempting to ward off his evil
foe still we know that Carlos is going
to take a magical motorcycle ride to the
Isle of the Lost
where he'll come face-to-face with his
roots taking up arms against evil it's
no easy feat which is why only the
bravest warriors will be up for the
challenge
Carlos is going to prove just how
courageous and selfless he truly is by
risking his own life to save the masses
this just goes to show how much Carlos
has grown since we first saw him flash
across the screen as time goes on Carlos
becomes less and less
enthralled by his mother's wardrobe he
lets his hair grow long and adapt some
more futuristic style Carlos's brand-new
look is 100% appropriate though
considering he'll soon be tasked with
saving auradon when we first meet Carlos
he had a boyish charm about him but now
it's obvious that he's grown into a
young and confident man he's ditched his
predominantly red white and black attire
for a full-body silver leather suit
despite the many changes he's undergone
carlos still manages to stay true to his
heritage so his new look still mirrors
his mother's colors but to a bare
minimum
whereas Carlos used to enjoy being
decked out in red from head to toe he
now only uses crimson to fill in minor
details
Carlos's new look is downright wicked
and he looks just about ready to put up
a fight if his personality has evolved
half as much as his exterior expect to
meet a brand new Carlos come descendants
3 Carlos Deville isn't your typical
villain in fact he isn't your typical
person ever since he was a kid Carlos
chose to go against his mother's evil
ways and help those in need
in fact he once saved Evie from mouths
wicked ways despite being raised to use
hurt and ridiculed those around him
Carlos never stooped down to a villains
levels for this reason Carlos earned the
reputation of being the sweetest BK on
the aisle
Carlos's evolution is downright amazing
and it deserves some praise who would
have thought that cruella de Vil's son
would grow up to be an animal rights
activist Carlos life changed for the
better when he befriended a little dog
named dude with King Ben and Deutz help
Carlos realized that judging something
or someone on their reputation was just
as bad as spreading rumors about them
once free of his mother's cruel grasp
Carlos was finally able to pursue his
own endeavors Carlos can now shower his
girlfriend with affection play video
games and eats chocolate at will gone
are the days when Carlos slept on the
floor of his mother's fur room he's no
longer gullible and timid instead he's
realistic and brave from now on Carlos
will forever be true to his feelings and
speak his mind no matter the
consequences Carlos now sees friendship
hope and love
for what they are strengths not
weaknesses so there you have it
Carlos de Vil's evolution from start to
finish before you go let us know why you
love Carlos in the comments section
below and be sure to let us know which
descendants characters you'd like to
cover next give this video a big thumbs
up if you think do the dog is the cutest
mutt in auradon and don't forget to
subscribe to the things for the latest
descendants news thanks for watching
we'll catch you next time
[Music]